frappé ligoté et enfermé dans le coffre
de sa voiture c'est le cauchemar qu'a
vécu hier une conductrice de taxi de 57
ans une information révélée par nos
confrères de la nr l'agresseur présumé
un client qu'elle avait pris à tour
direction chambord et ce soir en garde à
vue on ignore encore ses motivations son
arrestation a été rendue possible grâce
à la vigilance d'un autre conducteur de
taxi à la station essence d'un
supermarché de blois il avait remarqué
le sang sur les chaussures de
l'agresseur mais aussi entendu taper
dans le coffre de la voiture
ce soir les confrères de la conductrice
agressés sont sous le choc ils
connaissent bien la victime par ailleurs
la veille l'un d'eux avait semble-t-il
déjà eu affaire à l'agresseur devant la
gare de tours on retrouve alain
deschâtelets
huguette est loin d'être une débutante
25 ans qu'elle est au volant de son
véhicule au sein du gia des taxis de
tours ses collègues la décrivent comme
une femme de caractère franche et
courageuse parmi les 90 taxi de tours
elles ne sont plus que trois femmes à
exercer ce métier huguette fait
également partie du conseil
d'administration du groupement alors
forcément ici tout le monde la connaît
on est tous
complètement
abasourdis par ce qui s'est passé parce
que en plein jour comme ça maintenant
effectivement on n'exclut pas et on
garde toujours en tête que cette chose à
est toujours possible que ce soit le
jour que ce soit la nuit au siège des
taxis de tours ils sont nombreux à avoir
pris des nouvelles du guette tous sont
unanimes face à une agression les
chauffeurs n'ont que peu de moyens de
défense certains possèdent des bombes
lacrymogènes mais il n'existe aucun
signal d' alerte dans les voitures les
conducteurs sont donc quotidiennement
livrés à eux mêmes avec des inconnus
pourraient peut-être un jour que les
gens pensent à ce que ça soit aménagé et
peut-être avec quelque chose une alarme
quelque chose mais si car individus
vouvoie appuyer sur un bouton
automatiquement vous rentrez déjà dans
un truc où il se crée un milieu un peu
compliqué une ambiance compliquée donc
finalement rien à faire il n'y a pas
grand chose à faire mise à part avoir un
certainement plus de chances que ce qu'
il ya eu aujourd'hui selon plusieurs
témoignages le mis-en-cause aurait
essayé dès le samedi de se faire déposer
à chambord mais le chauffeur vers lequel
il se serait dirigé n'aurait pas accepté
la course trouvant l'individu louche
alors at il volontairement choisi une
femme quand il a renouvelé sa demande le
dimanche matin certains pensent que oui
il a peut-être préféré entre guillemets
avoir affaire à une femme plutôt qu'un
homme voilà une gaieté est un petit
gabarit on va dire mais très très très
dynamique donc je pense que même avec ce
qu'elle a subi elle n'a certainement pas
dû se laisser faire voilà donc
mais oui oui je pense que c'était ciblé
ce soir l'agresseur est toujours en
garde à vue il pourrait être poursuivi
au minimum pour enlèvement séquestration
et violences avec arme